my recent video the fatal flaw of free
market capitalism has generated a
healthy amount of discussion in some
circles anyway and so this led me to
performing a bunch of thought
experiments which were super fun and so
this video is the result and just as a
quick refresher anarcho-capitalism is a
stateless society where individuals are
free to contract with each other and
everything else is up to the free market
all the public services are privatized
and i was rather curious as to how this
would work in real life now one thing
that handcaps like to bring up to help
support the viability of that ideology
is the so-called icelandic commonwealth
which was for all intents and purposes a
proto-encaps society in the middle ages
now it did manage to exist from 930
until
1262-63 when the icelanders apparently
voted to ask the king of norway to take
over their country and to quote from the
icelandic commonwealth's wikipedia page
from the decline and fall section in the
early 13th century the age of the
storlongs the commonwealth began to
suffer from chaos and division resulting
from internal disputes originally the
goddard chieftains functioned more as a
contractual relationship than a fixed
geographic chieftaincy however by 1220
this form of communal leadership was
replaced by dominant regional
individuals who battled with one another
for more control one historian argues
that the chaos and violence of this
period stem from an imbalance of power
and changes in the nature of icelandic
warfare whereas the number of goddard
had been at least 39 in the early
icelandic commonwealth a few powerful
families had consolidated control over
most of the godard in the late 12th
century now i don't know about you but
this to me sounds awfully familiar and
my favorite part about this is that the
icelandic commonwealth failed so hard in
the end that people ended up inviting a
foreign desperate to invade their land
because even that was preferable to
living in icelandic and capistran now
this was in part a result of the king of
norway exerting pressure on iceland for
a longer time so some might say that
this is cheating and thus isn't fair
criticism but this line of thinking
leaves us with three possible options as
to why ice capistan fell number one
would be because of the nordic invasion
number two because people were
manipulated into voting for the takeover
and number three because people
misjudged the situation and made their
own call at the ballot box and i have
bad news for end caps all these options
prove my point they show you that an
ancap society would either fall victim
to a state's well-organized invasion
force or get subverted by propaganda or
people will vote on a field overreals
basis and end up screwing themselves
over
brexit
and i personally think that if a country
would transition into the end cap model
somewhere a military intervention
scenario would be its most likely end
and it would be super convenient too i
mean there would be no state to declare
war on there is no state you just roll
in with the tanks and announce martial
law even if some people would resist
it'll just be a handful of loosely
coordinated militias if that against a
regular army and of course if you have
some kind of very powerful high-tech
military hardware you need a very
complicated logistics chain to maintain
it you know billy joe can't just tow a
reaper drone to his shack to recalibrate
his targeting ai or something what an
average ncap commune could do at most is
maintain or create small arms and crude
explosives maybe so the end cap dream
stumbles right at the starting line and
right here right now i could just stop
bothering with all this but i'd like to
dig a little bit deeper let's give it
all to end caps the most ideal scenario
imaginable for the emergence of real
real-life anarcho-capitalism an
imaginary world where every country
transitioned into anarcho-capitalism at
the exact same time all corporations
were completely dissolved all nuclear
weapons were disarmed and all complex
military hardware beyond small arms was
disposed of all you have is people
living freely with their guns ready to
enter into voluntary contracts with each
other having inherited all the
infrastructure built out by the now
dissolved governments and everyone
getting a fresh start at capitalism so i
believe that this would be a perfect or
at least near perfect condition for
anarcho-capitalism so how will things
work out let's take a look wait what's
this oh that's right my channel has been
taken over by vladimir putin okay it
hasn't been actually taken over and
these folks are actually anti-putin and
they are the sponsors of today's video
bony right is a youtube channel that
dives into all kinds of topics and gives
you a deeper look into things such as
why prices have suddenly risen because
of the container shortage or how the
chip crisis is affecting us all their
latest video is a personal investigation
into russian vaccines whether they even
work and what exotic difficulties
russians must endure if they want to get
vaccinated it's some high quality
content with great animations no wonder
that russian language channels have more
than a million subs jesus christ don't
worry though bonyride is in english
you'll find the link in the description
thank you for checking out bonyride ads
like this helps support what i do and
now back to ancapestan
so our little simulation will have two
relevant parameters number one is that
everybody will act according to
irrational self-interest without
exception and number two there will be
no deus ex mahina type situations
meaning everything will develop
organically as a logical continuation of
the events that happened before so over
here we have a network of smaller
settlements each operating their own
basic infrastructure just like during
medieval times in these settlements
eventually some people start getting
more successful at capitalism than
others let's call them great men and
we'll be focusing on one of them this
fellow called billy bob living in the
town of einville now einville does have
its own little water system but the
water quality is not the greatest it's
drinkable but it tastes kind of funny
and if you have any sort of stomach
problems it just tends to make the
problem worse now billy bob runs a
saloon in town and he thinks the water
quality is hindering his sales because
it makes his liquor taste worse and to
help run his business smoother using his
knowledge of distillers he puts together
a water purifier so he can disconnect
from the local water system and save
money and also have better tasting
liquor now his water purifier ends up
being a success able to produce large
quantities of water with a low energy
cost which is somewhat even better
quality than the water from the system
now he produces more water than he needs
by a considerable margin so he starts
selling it off to people with those
profits plus his increased revenue from
liquor sales he puts together a second
machine in his free time this time he
works out some of the bugs and the new
machine turns out to be slightly more
efficient and produces even better
quality water he now sells a lot of
water and makes large amounts of money
now billy bob is forward thinking and
keeps reinvesting his revenue back into
his business with his profits he buys a
plot of land behind the saloon and
builds a huge water storage tank he also
builds out pipes to the farmlands nearby
and starts selling his water to the
farmers with his increasing profits he
hires workers to build and maintain
water purifiers soon enough he has
enough capital to offer a handsome
amount for the local water system the
owners like his offer and sell him all
that infrastructure after all they
weren't making as much money on it
anyway they didn't really know what they
were doing the water quality was bad
they had a large maintenance backlog and
most people in einville just went on
collecting rain water and boiling it
anyway so they are more than happy to
just pull the golden parachute and get
rid of all their problems and go on to
do something else following the
acquisition billy bob founds the bill
and robert water company now everyone in
town is his current or potential
customer billy bob has his workers
connect his purifiers to the system
filling the pipes with his water he also
spends on maintenance replacing rusty
pipes and leaky valves which increases
the water quality and reduces water loss
his customer base starts to grow rapidly
people happily sign the contract stating
that they'll get the water cheaper than
under the previous orders and at a
guaranteed higher quality they can also
disconnect from billy bob's pipes for
the equivalent of one thousand dollars
as a service fee but why would they the
water is cheap and great as time goes on
other people try to get in on the water
business too offering their own water
from their own purifiers only a few
people switch over though since
billywob's water is reasonably priced
and of high quality and there is a
thousand dollar disconnect fee which
nobody wants to pay but then a true
prodigy appears an even greater man who
creates a water purifier that's even
better than billy bob's worse he starts
selling the water from it and some
people actually switch over and they are
very satisfied with the water it's even
cheaper and even better quality and this
even greater man even starts making some
money on his business sucking away
profits from billy bob now billy bob
gets word of this so he visits this
prodigy personally and offers to buy out
his business but he gets rejected now
the actions of this prodigy directly
threaten billy bob's business he must
neutralize this threat as soon as he can
billy bob goes on to use his
considerable wealth and leverage to
artificially lower the price of water
even below the competitor's price
although he goes into the red somewhat
he has enough money stockpiled to
survive they produce so by virtue of
being a small business he also has to
lower his price to compete otherwise
nobody would buy water from him his
customers started windall many switching
back over to billy bob who announces a
500 water coupon bonus to be given to
all returning customers after months of
losses the prodigy is at the end of his
rope he spent every bit of money on
keeping his business alive he sold
absolutely everything he could now
living on the barest of necessities in
an empty apartment perhaps one month
away from eviction at this point billy
bob visits him again and makes a new
offer a very pretty sum of cash for his
business and a lucrative upper
management position within the bill and
albert water company together with a
luxury executive penthouse he will also
have access to a very generous
innovation fund which he can use to
invent even better water purifiers and
this time he doesn't have to worry about
not being able to pay the bills if his
inventions prove unsuccessful billy bob
takes all the financial risks and the
prodigy is free to unleash his creative
genius what's better for every
innovation he gets a huge bonus with the
added caveat that all of them will be
the property of the bill and robert
water company and cannot be made open
source the prodigy has to make a choice
he can refuse go broke get evicted in a
month and sleep under the bridge wrapped
in a filthy blanket hungry and sick
torturing himself with the thought of
the dream he lost or he can continue his
life's work of inventing purifiers and
fulfill his dreams in a position of
prestige and wealth high salary luxury
penthouse generous bonuses freedom to
innovate and all he needs to do for this
is sign the dotted line
and
he does he becomes general manager of
the bill and robert water company gets a
beautiful penthouse where just the
bathroom is twice as big as his entire
previous apartment as promised he gets
to tinker with his designs on the side
and gets huge bonuses for his work he
becomes a respected member of the
community and everyone admires him for
his talents and billy bob now controls
the town's entire water market he stops
the price dumping and returns to making
massive profits now even more since the
prodigy helps increase the efficiency
with his innovations that is but aside
from doing his business billy bob also
likes to read mainly about great men in
the past and what they did to succeed he
comes across the idea of buying out as
much as the production chain as possible
the chain that supplies the business
that is so billy bob might be selling
the water but it's not his company that
manufactures the pipes or mines the oar
to smelt the metal or makes the parts
for the purifiers and so he goes on to
acquire as many of these enterprises as
possible using the same tactic offering
management positions and large salaries
by the time he's done he can build out a
water supply system from scratch just
using his company resources he now owns
mines foundries machine building
workshops and optimizes their production
for his goals those enterprises might
suffer losses due to this but the water
company gets materials much cheaper and
the gains far outpace the losses which
billy bob of course ends up
cross-subsidizing but billy bob doesn't
stop there he becomes obsessed with
control he now owns all of his
production chain but decides he wants
more but what else can he acquire while
the other end of course his biggest
customers are farmers who use his water
for irrigation with bilibov's advanced
irrigation systems made by his foundries
and workshops the farms grew to the
point where they could not sustain
themselves with their own wells anymore
and so they became dependent on billy
bob's water but hey it's a great deal so
they're not complaining billy bob founds
the bill and robert agricultural company
and starts buying out all the land plots
around einville his tactics are the same
offer the owners generous terms and
occasionally high position and lucrative
salary if billy bob deems the owner to
be a potential valuable addition to his
team that is and so most landowners end
up taking his offer and those who
initially don't are either swayed by
secret deals where billboard offers them
a price well above market or by
threatening with accident squad and gold
happening to the pipes that feed those
particular plots one way or another
billy bob ends up owning all the land
plots around town satisfying his growing
urge for ownership and control for the
time being anyway and because of his
great public business practices nobody
opposes him everybody wants to see him
succeed he's a great manager a
benefactor of prodigies and his cheap
high quality water helps the local
industry supporting breweries
distilleries a paper mill and even a
paint factory his success is everyone
else's success and einville is booming
because of him a true great man he is
but the success begins to draw some
shady characters into the area raider
gangs from the abandoned areas in the
south start harassing the town the
townsfolk organized into a militia and
managed to fend off the attackers but
just barely dozens die to gunshot wounds
and the townsfolk come together on the
main square to honor the dead at the
ceremony billy bob delivers a speech
lamenting their heroic sacrifice he ends
his speech by announcing the foundation
of a permanent security force under his
control to defend the town so that
nothing like this will happen ever again
anyone can enlist the gear and training
are provided together with free company
housing and a good salary a few months
later blackwater security already has a
hundred members who aside from guarding
the perimeters also patrol inside
einville to keep up the order that way
people no longer have to bother with
organizing militias and neighborhood
watches and have more time to spend
freely the next raider attack gets
repelled much easier thanks to the
organized semi-professional defense
force though casualties are minimal the
raiders manage to do significant damage
to certain parts of the town billy bob
wants to pay for the reconstruction out
of his own pocket announcing his
intentions in front of a cheering crowd
he also suggests building a defensive
structure around the town which he would
gladly help finance but most of the
money would come from people's pockets
at first not everyone is on board with
the idea but in a few months following
raiders sightings and a massive pro war
campaign which appears to be grassroots
but is financed completely by billy pup
from the shadows the public opinion
shifts and the wall gets built around
einvale the town becomes completely safe
which gives a boost to its economy and
draws in a lot of people from all around
the area who move in for that safety and
stability soon enough ironville almost
doubles in population thanks to its
appeal and the generously low rent
prices offered by the pidlin robot real
estate company which aside from
apartments also builds a massive
fortification at the center of the town
as billbop's pet project it's an added
second line of defense that people can
retreat to in case the war got breached
this added security draws in even more
people and consequently causes
significant appreciation in property
prices everyone is in favor of building
the fort once completed billy bob moves
his entire headquarters inside it at
this point billy bob owns the water
system the land around town multiple
mines workshops foundries a huge number
of buildings in town a security force a
wall and a fort and all these are run by
the managers under him who also grow
empower and influence with him
organizing different aspects of life and
are only accountable to billy bob
personally billy bob is a great man who
has done so much for ironville and he
would like to see some more compensation
for his efforts he announces the need
for a contribution from everyone living
inside the walls to finance the upkeep
of all the defenses most people agree to
it and those who don't are offered to
move outside the walls if they refuse
blackwater security will simply evict
them now this is of course a risky move
in terms of pr so biliba proceeds to buy
up as many local news outlets as he can
or at least try to fill their ranks with
writers secretly paid by him despite his
efforts though word spreads around town
that billy bob has gone too far and
needs to be stopped still only a small
minority of the population takes part in
this the rest being more than satisfied
with their growing living standards
under billy bob anti-billy bob movements
are formed but are consequently squashed
by black water agents working with billy
bob's growing network of informants
members are tried in the blackwater
court system popularly accepted as the
biggest and most efficient body to
dispense justice in ironville over time
people inside the walls become a sort of
higher class citizenry who have access
to high quality public services in
exchange for their taxes and loyalty to
billy bob those outside the wolves don't
pay taxes but no public services are
provided to them unless they pay a hefty
quote-unquote outskirts premium and can
only be inside the town centre between
8am and 9pm those who want to move
inside the city walls won't be let in by
blackboard security unless they pay a
quote-unquote settlement premium a fee
designed to keep up the prestige of
living inside the walls those on the
outside have of course limited access to
all the jobs and opportunities on the
inside therefore they have to get by
mostly on agricultural work for which
they get russians and housing the new
unspoken rule spreads around town billy
bob will give you law and order
stability and prosperity but for that
you must pay your dues and not question
his authority under any circumstances
those who do get fined or even exiled
depending on the severity but for each
exile there are five newcomers to take
their place wanting to participate in
the stable economy and society ok
alright so what do we have here a
well-protected town with a fortified
administrative center outside there is a
lower class mostly working the fields
inside we have a privileged citizen
class and most aspects of life are
controlled by a sort of nobility who are
only accountable to the men above them
and of course most of everything is
owned by that man alone so through this
simulation by starting out with the most
ideal circumstances possible for an end
cap society to arise we ended up with a
sort of enlightened feudalism and why
wouldn't we you know capitalism is
fundamentally based on a government-like
hierarchy one that isn't democratic so
once you introduce a power vacuum by
ending the government it makes sense
that capitalism will fill that vacuum
but this time with a truly autocratic
structure you know i always hear these
libertarians and handcaps whine about
government tyranny and how taxes are
theft but i mean when was the last time
you had a say in how your workplace is
run hey when's the next ceo election
coming up the one you can vote in as
well as an employee not just the rich
shareholders okay so this was a lot of
fun actually and i think i'll be giving
it a second try because something must
have been wrong right henrico capitalism
can just turn into feudalism right well
don't you worry next time we'll
fine-tune the simulation of it and
experiment with some other possibilities
which are no less interesting in the
meantime thank you for watching and
please like and subscribe and also check
out my patreon link in the description
and i'll be seeing you next time
you